how to
start a conversation in a business
meeting um this is a really good
question
to answer because otherwise we're going
to be twiddling our thumbs
for this video i want to do something
different i actually want to share with
you
a virtual keynote that i gave at a big
global conference
called trend lab and in this keynote i
share
two really mind-blowing stats three
specific tools that can help you have
better conversations in business
meetings and one story that will make
you cringe
a little bit enjoy the video without
further ado let's
get into it
hey everyone uh thank you sophie for the
introduction
and trend miner for having me you know
we
show up to virtual conferences summits
events in person summits conferences
events
for content right we show up to get the
latest trends the latest ideas
hear from experts in the field and
oftentimes at the end of the conference
the most impactful meaningful part
are the connections that we walk away
with all the connections that happen in
between
the conference and so i'm really excited
to be in cyberspace with you today
trend miner's done a phenomenal job
partnering with conversation starter
to create a platform you for you to be
able to connect
rather than just consume information so
i'm chad littlefield before i tell you
anything that i know
i would love to know what is something
you know
really well right you know
collectively everybody watching this
right now is way smarter than just me
and so i want to know what do you know
and so in the comments feel free to
share what is something that you know
really well
and one of the reasons that i wanted to
start off with this is
the first and primary reason i think
making digital connections is so
immensely valuable
and that is this concept that everybody
you will ever meet knows something you
don't
everyone you'll ever meet knows
something you don't and for any of you
who are familiar with bill nye
the science guy uh that's a pretty
lovely quote coming from him
so what i know really well to take my
own medicine
and answer my own question is how do you
ask powerful questions to create
conversations
that matter and so what i hope to do
today
is share a couple stats that might blow
your mind
and then three really concrete tools
that you can use to make your
conversations better
and so the first stat and my question to
you just to ponder is
how many questions do you think we ask
per day
and let's actually break that down how
many questions do you think kids
between the ages of three and five ask
per day on average kids ask 300 to
400 questions per day and any of you who
are parents
know this quite well right how about
adults
how many questions do you think adults
ask per day
6 to 12 6 to 12
questions per day and i'm assuming some
of those are when are you coming home
and what's for dinner and some other
very mundane
uh things and so whoa what happened
there's this there's this national
international curiosity gap now i'm not
advocating that we go back to 300 to 400
questions
but i am going to suggest that if you
want to make really meaningful
connections
that knowing how to ask really great
questions
is a phenomenal tool to help get you
there and so
what i want to unpack today is
how do we ask questions because think
about
you know when you typically whether it's
virtually or in person when you meet
another person for the very first time
and you can ask any question you can say
anything you want you're meeting this
person for the very first time
what questions do we typically ask
how are you where are you from
what do you do
and even in a room full of a lot of
smart people
a virtual room full of a lot of smart
people we tend to only ask one of three
or four questions
when we meet somebody for the first time
this is interesting right
we could ask anything but we tend to ask
one of three or four very safe questions
i think the reason for that is that our
brains are wired for that right if
you've ever gone to a wedding
nobody walks into a wedding and says oh
who do i know
least in the room and can i go sit down
next to them
no right we go we our default is to say
who do we know most
what's most comfortable and to gravitate
toward that
and so i'm going to invite us as you use
conversation starter throughout the
conference
and in your conversations moving on
beyond
trend lab i'm going to invite you to
think about what would happen
if you changed your question count and
you ask seven questions instead of six
in a day what would happen if you
followed your natural
genuine curiosity so uh before i show
these three tips
why what's the point organizationally
right
um google is a company that really likes
data right it's a company filled with
engineers and very left-brained
folks and they love data and a few years
ago they launched this giant research
internal research project to unpack and
uncover what are the characteristics of
the highest performing teams
at google and the number one
characteristic that they found was not
the
uh degree or it wasn't the level of
technical experience in the group it
wasn't the
perfect personality myers-briggs blend
the number one characteristic of high
performing teams
at google was the degree of
psychological safety
in that team which is really phd
academic term for interpersonal trust
can i be myself at work can i share my
ideas and trust that they'll be even if
people disagree that they get
constructed rather than smashed down
and so i would argue that if we
extrapolate that data a little bit
that the number one characteristic of
really high performing conversations
really meaningful conversations
is often the degree of psychological
safety in that conversation
and so what can you do to create that so
three
ideas that come from uh
my book ask powerful questions create
conversations that matter
so if you look the the book and the
tools and what i
my work is structured into this tier so
wouldn't it be really convenient
right if you could just snap your
fingers
and make the person that you were
meeting with feel like you were willing
to know them like you saw them like you
heard them you got them and you were
ultimately with them
right but especially as an engineer if
you consider yourself
uh any bit of socially awkward and
conversation is just like
a bit of a slog for you right this is
pretty hard to create actually
and so flipping it around are a series
of tools that i want to unpack i want to
give you the first three
spark notes version so the first one is
intention
intention is a really interesting word
and the um the latin root the word
intention
actually means to stretch
right and i love that concept because i
think an intention is very different
than an
objective in a conversation or then a
mission or a purpose right
if you enter a networking conversation
with the objective
to get something from another person
that person is going to feel like
garbage right so the idea of an
intention and stretching an intention
yeah i think a really great intention
stretches
over the needs of everybody in the
conversation and not just you so it
serves more than
just your needs and so my invitation
or the tool here is in your
conversations as you're using
conversation starter and
going through your work life the tool
here is to get clear about your
intention
and share it with the person that it
affects now this is a little bit
unnatural for us because very often we
have intentions
that might affect other people but very
rarely do we actually
share those intentions with the people
that they affect
and when we don't do that that's
actually manipulation so when you're in
a networking conversation and you're
wanting to get a deal you're wanting to
get
some information you're trying to get
them to do something
that you want without necessarily
telling them that's manipulation and so
my invitation is before you split out
into conversation starter which by the
way just
a little digital inception here so uh
conversation starter
is going to look like this this i
printed out a web page
whoa um and so find this a little pink
button
wherever your digital spheres are to set
up a profile on conversation starter
so that you can be paired
algorithmically with
the right people to be in conversation
and connection with
and my invitation is when you get to
those get clear about what is your
intention
or the way that conversations uh starter
phrases it what is your request
and share that with the person that
affects share that with the person that
you're actually talking to
tip number two one of my absolute
favorite questions
what are you curious about right now
the most intelligence from the most
intelligent to the least intelligent
human beings on the planet
people are really good at picking up on
natural genuine curiosity
so kids right 300 to 400 questions a day
have lots of natural curiosity
adults six to 12 questions per day
somewhere along the line we've lost our
curiosity
and so tip number two is to follow your
natural genuine curiosity
based on what someone is sharing with
you and so the best way to trick your
brain into listening really effectively
is to hear what somebody else is saying
stop thinking about yourself and all
your experience and how you can relate
to that
and just think about what are you
curious about
right now all right what are you curious
to know about that person
right now and follow up with a sentence
that
ends in a question mark not a period so
ask a question
right it's somewhere along the line as
adults we learned the pattern of
uh you speak then i speak you speak then
i speak
and it's a really great tool in
conversation to have you speak
i ask you speak i speak you ask
right to weave in questions throughout
cool so follow your natural genuine
curiosity based on what you're hearing
somebody say
the third and final tool that i'll drop
with you today i want to share in the
form of a story so i used to work for
this organization
called world and conversation and my job
was to
sit down and have conversation
facilitate and lead conversations
with strangers from very different
backgrounds about very difficult
uh topics of conversation and so my job
was to
break the ice and make that as least
awkward as possible
and create a really meaningful
conversation so 90 minutes picture a
group of people sitting down in a circle
talking to each other
sometimes about race relations politics
long-term conflict
things that are not typically discussed
especially with strangers right
and so in order for that conversation to
go well going back to that google study
we've got to have a high degree of
psychological safety
in order to make that really work and so
um i was teaching a bunch of other
facilitators how to do this and i don't
think you can teach people
how to ask questions without actually
experiencing it and so we stopped the
workshop was a middle of a three-hour
workshop we stopped the workshop
and we said you've got three minutes to
use the tools we've shared with you
about
getting clear about your intention and
sharing it and following your natural
curiosity to build a relationship of
trust
with three strangers go and the rooms
those 20
students in the room were kind of
freaking out they were not interested in
doing this uh exercise
so i don't believe in asking somebody to
do something i'm not willing to do
myself
and so on this particular time i was
like all right if i've got to do this
i'm going to run a quick errand and so i
head downtown and to a convenience store
i pick out a couple items that i want
and as i'm checking out there's a woman
who's has bright colored tattoos
all over her neck and i'm like oh i
teach this stuff i'm going to follow my
natural curiosity so i get to the front
and i say i'm just so curious
what's the story behind your tattoos and
she goes i like the colors
oh right did not build a relationship
with trust
we get back to the room all the students
come back the
energy in the room is electric because p
everybody's just had three experiences
successes or failures aiming to build a
relationship a trust and one student
quiets everybody down he's like whoa i
have to share this first we go to
debrief this
i've got to share this first i i was
ticked
when you asked me to do this i did not
want to do this and so i said if i have
to do this
i might as well get something done while
i'm at it and so i walked down to on the
convenience store
i picked out a couple items that i
really really
uh needed and i got to the front and
there was a cashier
wearing bright colored tattoos all over
her neck
and i looked at her and i said
i'm just curious i have to ask how
annoying does it get
when people ask you about your tattoos
she just starts gushing with information
and so she starts gushing and she and
what he says she specifically said oh my
gosh i have no idea sometimes i wish i
never got them i feel like wearing a
turtleneck
in the summer to cover them up in fact
there was just this guy in here asking
me
what's the story behind your tattoos
so my question to you to share the final
the third and final tip with you is
what was the difference between his
success
and my failure i would argue
that it was empathy it was in that
moment that he was able to put
at least one of his feet into somebody
else's shoes
and so as you dive into your
conversations through conversation
starter think about
uh what is somebody else wanting caring
about needing
and be able to ask follow your natural
curiosity rooted in
empathy for the other person because
there's a very powerful shift that
happens
in conversation when we stop thinking
about this person
and we start thinking about the other
person
i'm chad littlefield it was awesome to
share some time in cyberspace with you
uh go create some conversations that
matter have
an awesome day
here's a bonus question for you
[Music]
you